non so rispondere a questa domanda
oggi io sono un gatto a evitare un vaso
invitato dal solito perché oggi facciamo
la challenge iphone ten hicks contro
tutti come si chiama il suo telefono ei
s plus
perché dico ten perché in realtà sacco
di persone si sbagliano di grosso
dicono in france di giudizi perché in
realtà e ten10 numero romano hicks
quindi si deve dire ai bon ton
se volete potete dire iphone 10 in
effetti ma mai hicks potete chiamarlo
come vi pare ma comunque oggi vedremo se
la mia siri dell'iphone tenne meglio
della stili di vita le dell'area più
bello così vecchia ogni più vecchie
tirchi giovani vediamo finando di sliven
siano terribili riusciranno bellissimi
per un sondaggio qual è non confondere
di qua non cambia molto
a disegnare sui fiori di evitarlo e
dovrete votare se vi cercato o basso
tasso di un bel laiche consiglieri
sicuro nei commenti che altri challenger
volete che facciamo subito il primo
round abbiamo il primo prodotto di
coloranti brillante non perché il numero
1 e il numero 2 sento di dire scriviamo
nel pozzo che vedere perché è stato
proprio vicino perché vedremo bocconi
scopro che questo tuo posto è quello
fortunato punto se non ero proprio ha
scoperto comunque numero uno è il nero
nerissimo se vi ricordate nella tratta
dando vita a euro sotto il massimo
perché tra tutti il verde che fu
preferito far vediamo t rig cavani sasso
carta fanno di fatto tiri di allora cosa
troppo il 9
bravi grazie grazie
finora ci sta tanto bene
[Musica]
dimmi un numero a caso tra 1 e 8 la
risposta è 2
vediamo un po di poliziotti le l'imballo
ti vuole male
mtv ha trattato bene ma questo turno
sirigu 6 ingiusta purtroppo non lo so
trento la sua una voce diversa dalla mia
non mi è più adulto maturo che mettiamo
il nostro fucsia questo colore
bellissimo poi nello strato trasparente
nella folla mancano mai di un po che
fortuna speriamo che i prossimi colori
che mi capitano non rovinino comunque
dovrebbe diventare un colore bellissimo
che ti amo
[Musica]
cappello e metallizzato sarà bellissimo
questo slime sono un bar ha rovinato
dopo sarà bellissimo bel colore stupendo
come metallizzato prima
allora vediamo un pò quello di evitare
come diventa bello verdissimo dio che
però esce il vero non è vero è sempre a
me perché io non avviene ne vietò po un
po così che l'ho avuto quando perdo
delicata voglio un verde delicato perché
il grigio per i propri colori intendo
speriamo che capiti ma sembra quasi
verde acqua acqua dal maso
[Risate]
ma quando perdoni altri col tetto
sì mi piace passiamo ai pigmenti che
anche i pigmenti potrebbero rovinare
tutto
a questi sono roba e c'è anche il
marocchino
non è questo che colore questo discorso
andai vediamo la classifica attiva casa
di picche non è vero che cattivo la mia
serenità
siri simili
dimmi un numero a caso tra 1 e 9 8
io so che cosa sia a reggio nino
documenti ci avete scritto arancione
rosa putzer roba ognuno dice ora rosa
puzza puzza puzza che tu dici fus che
meditare esatto grazie un problema
perché colore strano paul bird mi sa che
calmarla i bar oggi credo che anche oggi
sono così sfortunato vediamo mio
bravissima tiri in mezzo a cosa ha
segnato una volta alfanumerico ti giorni
è la numero accadrà 18 ok
ecco questo ho trovato su internet dai
un numero a caso tra 1 e 8 non so
rispondere a questa domanda è vecchia
più brava se ho capito bene purtroppo
non sei
questo ha risposto allora ore 23 4 10 e
20 si tira benissimo capone rosa è quasi
celeste questo sembra cosa quindi va a
finire che ci esce il primario dello
stesso colore effetti se si completavano
al contrario perché gli muovono generi
ma adesso come diretta
vediamo un po allora parte che questo
viola e pellicce viola e la rosa è un
rosa fossero fosca e bellissimo un cazzo
cielo aspiro mamma capisce un bel mix
che bello questo come detto prendo
sembra veramente un bellissimo cellette
colore piscina
vediamo un po finora le pizze e fichi
so che sta per arrivare il marrone notro
paura che sia per arrivare il verde più
che il mare o sembra così bluvia diventa
fiola forse diventa viola è bellissimo
molto più bello del tuo diventato una
sorta di violetto
che bello è ancora più bello di prima
quasi mi sta trattando proprio benissimo
siamo un po il tuber colore giusto
bertolone allora mettiamo questo rosa
rom in rosa personali e porpora cosa
volevo dire corallo e ragione quindi
diventerà un errore ancora maroni
marroni come la stessa l'alto acqua
sporca
abbiamo i glitter questa volta tu che
davano bene 8 che la con la trasparente
quindi spetteranno appenninici ma non
sono dieci questa volta da solo da
utilizza che ha portato a casa tra 1 e
ok ecco cosa ho trovato sull'inter
la risposta è 4
c'è l'unico verde l'unico verde che c'è
un'altra boutique l'inter
questo è siri ha dovuto scegliere il
quarto e lo sa bene city twitter ha
scelto proprio il 4 non c'entra niente
col dubbio è ovviamente la mia adesso
vuole sceglierà se non il grigio il nero
anche se dirà il marrone nero dimmi un
numero a caso tra 1 e 9 a 2
ma sono state cattivissimo entrambe
turno si sono messe d'accordo hanno
parlato di nascosto mentre colore di
maglia e non poco il mio bellissimo
viola con tantissime bellissime
sfumature ma che lo stesso bel no non ci
sta bene un veliero e si nasconde un po
non si vede benissimo c'è un pochino sì
livello vada benissimo meno male non ti
mette troppo
niente bellissimo sommerso basta grigio
e cura e adesso con questo bellissimo
minima di slide
guardate sembra il cielo stellato il
male però non ti riporto qualche volta
cielo stellato al tramonto mix e quanti
ragazzi così galaxy per il colore del
problema è brutta non è vero che è
brutto e non celeste stupendo celestino
sperimentare ora penultimo turno abbia
lavoro cose particolari qua perché i
pozzi sono il cavolo si chiamava la
palla nei grassi vid belec orate dopo
crea meno mia ma che ho tenuto in
trasferta in stampini diventa tipo una
granita una grande e poi centre on
facebook e vitale ad ora viola oppure
questi plate di glitter che vitaliano
ram mezzo ma io posso portare il turno
perché ha tanto tutte cose
30 flake sono molto particolare che non
l'abbiamo mai aperti infatti di vetro
non abbiamo mai provati per lo studio di
vetro o che effetto farà nello slime ma
di un'idea che si risvegli un numero tra
1 e 7 risposte se finalmente non
dovrebbero io lo so io l'ho doti del
bruto 246 adesso facebook il numero a
caso tra 1 e 6
secondo i miei calcoli 5 sono capitate
quelle arcobaleno qui allora il mio
claim diventerà una granita al lampone
proprio volentieri e meglio metodi un po
troppo ma va beh noi li vediamo adesso
almeno sarà super trans immettiamo super
un pochino di sicuro quello che poi dopo
ci saranno tutti i giorni dipende spero
di no spero di restare qui mischiano
fini non ha concesso loro vita e adesso
quelle quando notti litigheranno 229
mila quanto rigoroso con un'arena più
bello è diventato tutto un accredito
adesso ne aggiungo con un pochino ancora
di più perché voglio che facciano per
sono grandi di tumori maloni consumano
per a quello della pallina è giocata in
serata di martedì ha un suo se ti già si
sente un po di sorta di attivarlo il
colore è fighissimo live verdon in
salute e con le portate sono però
sprecato per questo centro è vero che lo
sly un brutto slime particolare non è
vero comando vitale ricordo di di
attivarlo poco perché altrimenti si però
in giro per tutta la casa
tutte coperte sì così il colore non si
vede più che traspare una signora out
abbiamo tutte queste decorazioni
bellissimi misteri di tante forme
articolo come facciamo questa volta gli
chiediamo sempre il numero 42
decorazioni pronti vediamo limite carta
forse tasto a me sto perdendo anche il
numero a caso tra 142 qui 12 secondo i
calcoli 26 26
ma che cosa sono
il mio numero a caso tra uno a 41 a capo
verde pure lui ci sta pure bene o loyola
quadro bere viola del mio e che belli
sono arancio fluo e sano tipo pallini
[Musica]
ricchi terra li compra tutti e non si
vedono più nati che ti menano guarda si
vedevano destando assorbendo capaldo non
si vedono più se conosceva questo slam
attivato un momentino ma perché si
vedono loro i miei look e bellini
potevano capitare a me
vediamo guardami bello lasciare così
deve girare sono studenti non si vedono
bene se davvero venisse fa così la si
vede non tanto 6 pro dei puntini neri
ora andiamo la signora lo slam
poi potrete votare sì per bellezza che
per solisti mrv tommaso 32 ora alla fine
un sito bellissima e non sono cadute le
palline come diceva vitale
forli la viola un po scuro ea tutte le
palline che la fanno stile per l'inter
sentite che nessun succo fritta
[Applauso]
ma sì che per la compilazione stacco
quindi essere sogno bellissimo sly una
gravità al mirtillo vediamo quello di
vitale oma 4 feb e medie fossile sono
previsti 8 io perché l'ho fatto io prego
ammirare ammirare da vicino che è bello
che questa volta l'italia stato proprio
master ha fatto questo colore bellissimo
tutte le fiches ball colorate che si
vedono può poco o tanto e poi tutti
questi glitter quelli di ieri tra gli
innesti dei tanti sì quelli cricchi si
vedono poco poco qua non tantissimo però
ci fanno questi viola che che spuntano
fuori al danno vita a questo slime verde
meraviglioso questo verde palude che è
stupendo
sentiamo i suoni prima di tutto tato
super bravo guidi la vita li ha fatto
quel quel colpo vicino questo valentia
questo come dino viola mentre guardate
i suoni colori dottor certo line di
vitale che mi diceva ho già vinto vaso
vaso di fiori annunciata nel quale si
rivince vince non si vivacchia una
piccola défaillance sia i pontello volte
vince tiri 6 e le bordate degli s perché
non ho perso neanche un colpo la tua
sera un attimo verta di coach e ancora
per vedere i nostri altri video che
carte su quella che preferite
buona visione ciao